das ist ein film über die macht der
zentralbanken
zentralbanken haben die macht
wirtschaftliche politische und soziale
veränderungen zu bewirken und
so gehen sie dabei vor
pearl harbor siebter dezember 1941
[Musik]
dieser film basiert auf einem buch von
professor richard werner
[Musik]
lang lebe die kaiserliche armee
die prinzen des yen
zentralbanken und die transformation der
wirtschaft
[Musik]
ich gelobe treue zur flagge der
vereinigten staaten von amerika
[Musik]
die atombombe
wir werden um 9 uhr 30 in yokohama
ankommen die ausschaffungs priorität
richtet sich nach dem ausschaffungs
zeitplan
[Musik]
general douglas macarthur traf am 30
august
1945 auf dem marine flugplatz azubi in
der nähe von yokohama ein
als er aus seinem flugzeug stieg blieb
oben an der treppe stehen steckte eine
hand in die hüfttasche spannte den
kiefer um seine maiskolben pfeife und
betrachtete das eroberte land
sie wurde mehrmals wiederholt damit alle
pressefotografen eine gute aufnahme
machen konnten
die demokratie sollte dem japanischen
volk eingeimpft werden als hätte es noch
nie von etwas anderem gehört
unser problem liegt im kopf der japaner
diese köpfe können wie unsere gute oder
schlechte dinge tun abhängig von der art
die ideen die in sie hineingelegt werden
[Musik]
mögliche bucchi stücke in denen loyale
samurai auftreten wurden verboten oder
stark zensiert ebenso wie bücher und
filme über die bombardierungen von
hiroshima und nagasaki
trikot cartoons im ak satirische
karikaturen über metapher und die
erwähnung der besatzung sensor waren
strengstens untersagt
die kommission befindet sie für schuldig
im sinne der anklage und verurteilt sie
zum tode durch den strang
yamashita bedankt sich bei der
kommission für den fairen verlauf seines
prozesses
der damalige premierminister im
pazifikkrieg general tokio sagte während
seines prozesses keiner dieser japaner
würde es wagen gegen den willen des
kaisers zu handeln
er wurde sofort abgebrochen und eine
woche später erklärte torri
pflichtbewusst der kaiser habe den
frieden immer geliebt und gewollt
generali de quito rio der die offizielle
verantwortung für die führung des
krieges übernahmen und alles tat um
seinen kaiser zu entlasten
mcaffee bemerkte später vor dem us senat
dass sich die japaner in bezug auf die
moderne zivilisation wie ein 12 jahre
alter junge verhielten
[Musik]
du interessierst dich für das unbekannte
das mysteriöse das unerklärliche deshalb
bist du hier windows server als der
krieg vorbei war hatten sich die
kreditbücher der banken verschlechtert
bei den vermögenswerten der banken
handelte es sich hauptsächlich um kriegs
anleihen und krediten zerstörte
industrien damit war der gesamte
bankensektor praktisch bankrott
dieses problem konnte von der
japanischen zentralbank leicht gelöst
werden sie musste nur die faulen papiere
des bankensektors mit neu geschaffenen
reserven auf kaufen und ihnen gutes geld
für oft wertlose vermögenswerte geben
die ersten beiden zentralbankgouverneure
der nachkriegszeit wurden von der
amerikanischen besatzungsmacht ernannt
wurde zum ersten nachkriegs gouverneur
der japanischen zentralbank ernannt doch
kurz nach seinem amtsantritt wurde er
von der staatsanwaltschaft wegen
kriegsverbrechen angeklagt und musste
zurücktreten
nach einer allgemeinen amnestie für
mutmaßliche kriegsverbrecher die
öffentliche ämter bekleideten wurde er
1951 zum botschafter in den vereinigten
staaten ernannt als er von seinem
botschafterposten im jahr 1954 ab trat
wurde er erneut zum gouverneur der
zentralbank ernannt
acht oder neun team nach der amnestie
für kriegsverbrecher im jahr 1951 wurde
ein großteil der japanischen kriegs
bürokraten wieder in ihre positionen aus
der kriegszeit versetzt dazu gehörten
politiker aus der kriegszeit und die
meisten bürokraten des innenministeriums
die für die gedankenpolizei zuständig
gewesen waren und von denen einige in
das bildungsministerium wechselten
japan ist der schlüssel zum schicksal
des fernen ostens noch einmal zum
zweiten mal während des vormarsches der
modernen geschichte haben diese worte
dringende notwendigkeit
die tour wird um unruhen auf dem lande
zu verhindern die den kommunisten in
china in die hände spielten leiteten die
amerikaner die umverteilung von land von
großgrundbesitzern an ihre pächter ein
die kapitalistische elite japans die
sogenannte sei dazu wurde wegen ihrer
unterstützung eines verbrecherischen
krieges gesäubert und von weiteren
geschäftlichen aktivitäten
ausgeschlossen
im grunde genommen hat die us besatzung
die faschistische politik der 30er jahre
die die reform faschistischen bürokraten
während des krieges nicht umsetzen
konnten zu ende geführt wie die
landreform und die seibert zur politik
ja es ist eine sehr seltsame begegnung
von japanischen kriegs faschisten und
amerikanischen new deal an
[Musik]
das parlament sitzt von japan senat und
repräsentantenhaus
in japan randalierten fanatische
studenten und linke gruppen tage lang um
den gegenseitigen verteidigungs vertrag
mit amerika zu verhindern die
sozialistischen abgeordneten
inszenierten einen aufstand im parlament
die polizei vertrieb sie um die ordnung
wiederherzustellen
[Applaus]
der redner wurde auf das podium getragen
und rief die sitzung in der der vertrag
angenommen wurde zur ordnung
[Musik]
1957 wurde der ehemalige
kriegsverbrecher der klasse a
kinobesuche premierminister von japan
er war während des krieges general toews
minister für handel und industrie
gewesen dessen zuständigkeitsbereich von
munition bis zur sklavenarbeit reichte
während hitlers kriegs
wirtschaftsminister albert speer in
berlin spandau im gefängnis saß war sein
japanischer gegenpart ministerpräsident
des landes
obwohl kiki nach dem krieg ein
verfechter der demokratie wurde hatte er
sich vor und während des krieges als
nationalsozialist bezeichnet
mit dem geld von verbrecher sind die
karten industrieunternehmen und cad
schmiergeldern baute gysi die
liberaldemokratische partei zu einem
mächtigen politischen apparat aus
in japan in japan stammten viele der
wichtigen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen führer der nachkriegszeit
aus einer elitären gruppe von bürokraten
aus der kriegszeit die japan in den
krieg getrieben hatten
die liberaldemokratische partei blieb
fast 40 jahre lang an der macht
willkommen zu hause auf japanisch für
diese amerikanischen soldaten nach einem
einsatz in korea kehren sie zu ihrem
stützpunkt in japan zurück wo sie kurz
zuvor noch als besatzungstruppen
stationiert waren und wie kehren sie
zurück wie werden sie von den menschen
empfangen deren land sie besetzen nicht
als ober herren nicht als feinde nicht
als männer denen man misstraut die man
fürchtet und denen man es übel nimmt
sondern als freunde
[Musik]
im zentralen tokioter stadtteil jutta
hatte das finanzministerium seinen sitz
von hier aus kontrollierte das
ministerium die meisten bereiche der
japanischen wirtschaft
das finanzministerium war das mächtigste
ministerium und die zentralbank musste
dem finanzministerium bericht erstatten
beamte des finanzministeriums ernteten
ehrfurcht und respekt und ehemalige
ministerialbeamte erhielten
einflussreiche posten als leiter
öffentlicher und privater einrichtungen
[Musik]
in einem bereich hatte das ministerium
jedoch keine tatsächliche kontrolle und
zwar über den umfang der kreditschöpfung
und deren zuteilung über die von der
bank of japan der japanischen
zentralbank entschieden wurde
sie sagten dem finanzministerium und der
öffentlichkeit und den journalisten wie
er betreiben geldpolitik über den
leitzins und sie ließen das
finanzministerium über ihre zinspolitik
bestimmen aber die herrschaft wurde
nicht über die zinspolitik erreicht
sondern über die geldmenge
guidance ein verfahren in dem eine
zentralbank den geschäftsbanken quoten
für das kreditwachstum und die
kreditvergabe vor gibt es
[Musik]
funktioniert folgendermaßen man nennt
des window guidance die japanische
zentralbank hat den banken einfach
gesagt wie viel sie im kommenden quartal
verleihen müssen und an welchen
wirtschaftssektor
die japanische zentralbank erteilte
einzelnen banken viertel jährlich
anweisungen über die höhe der kredite
und darüber welchen industriezweigen sie
zuzuordnen waren alle kredite wurden
nach sektoren und teil sektoren
aufgeschlüsselt und die groß
kreditnehmer mussten namentlich
aufgeführt werden
die zentralbank konnte entscheiden
welche projekte gefördert und welche
ausgebremst werden sollten indem sie
diktierte an wen und wofür die banken
kredite vergeben konnten
das war das system der kriegswirtschaft
angepasst an die produktion von
konsumgütern
die 95 millionen einwohner japans
genießen heute ein nationales einkommen
das nur von den vereinigten staaten und
den wohlhabenden nationen westeuropas
übertroffen wird
es ist kein gutes system für
kapitalisten aber für die bevölkerung
hat es eine menge reichtum geschaffen
eine sehr gleichmäßige einkommens und
vermögensverteilung ein sehr hohes
wachstum und eine sehr schnelle
steigerung der lebensqualität und des
lebensstandards
allein im jahr 1959 wuchs die wirtschaft
um 17 prozent das system der
kriegswirtschaft hatte jedoch zur folge
dass ganze industriezweige nicht um
gewinne sondern um marktanteile
konkurrierten
die unternehmen kämpften bis zum
bankrott um marktanteile
dieses phänomen wurde bald erkannt und
als überhöhter wettbewerb bezeichnet die
lösung war die bildung von expliziten
oder impliziten kartellen
in der bank im bankensektor fungierte
die window guidance als
kontrollmechanismus da die japanische
zentralbank die anzahl und den wert der
von den banken vergebenen kredite
vorgeben konnte
infolgedessen änderte sich die
rangordnung der banken in der
nachkriegszeit nie außer nach fusionen
ein banker sagte ohne die window
guidance würden wir bis zum harakiri
miteinander kämpfen
das leistungsbilanzdefizit der usa
steigt auf den höchsten stand seit neun
jahren das ausmaß des anstiegs hat viele
ökonomen überrascht
während kartelle den wettbewerb
innerhalb japans kontrollierten gab es
solche grenzen nicht wenn es um
internationale märkte ging
japanische konzerne wurden bald auf
vielen märkten der welt dominant
in amerika in amerika wurden formelle
anhörungen im kongress abgehalten unter
titeln wie produktivität lektionen für
amerika
leading economic faires führende
wirtschafts theorien besagen dass nur
freie märkte zum erfolg führen können
doch japan ist innerhalb von jahrzehnten
zur zweitgrößten volkswirtschaft der
welt aufgestiegen
ohne sich nur auf die unsichtbare hand
der freien märkte zu verlassen
[Musik]
japans nachkriegs wirtschaft war eine
vollständig mobilisierte
kriegswirtschaft wobei die produktion
von waffen auf konsumgüter umgestellt
wurde
es ist besser für die japanische
zentralbank nicht aufzufallen und so
still zu sein wie der wald eines
ländlichen schreins peace imada
gouverneur der japanischen zentralbank
von 1946 bis 54
da sich die japanische zentralbank als
meisterin der freien märkte präsentierte
galt die window guidance als
peinlichkeit in offiziellen
veröffentlichungen wurde sie entweder
nicht erwähnt oder ihre rolle herunter
gespielt in dem die kredit kontrollen
als freiwillig bezeichnet wurden
wann immer sich das finanzministerium
über die kreditvergabepolitik der
japanischen zentralbank erkundigte
ließen sich die mitarbeiter der
japanischen zentralbank auf komplexe
diskussionen voller fachjargon ein um
den prozess für laien um durchschaubar
zu machen
im november 1965 kam die erste serie
japanischer staatsanleihen auf den markt
von nun an übten die politiker wenn sie
mehr geld ausgeben wollten nicht mehr
druck auf die zentralbank sondern auf
das finanzministerium aus das
ministerium würde also letztlich die
aufsicht über einen immer größer
werdenden staatsschulden berg führen
[Musik]
die 1980 er jahre waren eine ära der
finanziellen regulierung in der
industrialisierten welt die meisten
industrieländer hoben ihre
beschränkungen für den kapitalverkehr
auf
in japan in japan forderte tasche sasaki
ein ehemaliger gouverneur der
japanischen zentralbank einen fünf
jahres plan für die umgestaltung und
liberalisierung der japanischen
wirtschaft
wenn 96 im jahr 1986 schlug die
beratende gruppe für die wirtschaftliche
umstrukturierung unter der leitung des
ehemaligen gouverneurs der japanischen
zentralbank herr homeyer cover einen auf
zehn jahre angelegten wirtschaftsreform
plan vor mit dem der lebensstandard der
japaner an denen des westens angeglichen
werden sollte
[Musik]
in dem vorschlag heißt es für japan ist
jetzt die zeit gekommen einen
historischen wandel in seiner
traditionellen wirtschaftspolitik und
seinem lebensstil vorzunehmen
ohne diesen wandel kann es keine weitere
entwicklung für japan geben
der bericht las sich wie ein
wunschzettel der us handels unterhändler
er begann mit forderungen nach einer
verwaltungsreform und der abschaffung
bürokratischer befugnisse das ziel war
die umgestaltung der gesamten politik
die abschaffung des kriegs
wirtschaftssystems und die einführung
einer freien marktwirtschaft nach
amerikanischem vorbild
diejenigen mitglieder der beratergruppe
die eine abweichende meinung äußerten
wurden von ihren aufgaben entbunden
die berichte in der presse waren sehr
kritisch beobachten erkannten den
radikalen charakter des plans erschien
viel zu ehrgeizig er forderte eine
umfassende revolution aller teile des
japanischen wirtschaftlichen politischen
und sozialen systems
[Musik]
obwohl der bericht klar formulierte was
gewollt war spieker sich peinlich
darüber aus wie diese ziele erreicht
werden sollten der einzige hinweis dem
bericht versteckt war lautete bei der
umsetzung dieser empfehlungen kommt der
steuer und geldpolitik eine wichtige
rolle zu
[Musik]
die japanische zentralbank hat immer
gesagt dass das japanische system
abgeschafft werden sollte es sollte
einfach komplett abgeschafft werden und
der kapitalismus nach amerikanischem
vorbild sollte eingeführt werden ob sie
damit einverstanden sind oder nicht ist
eine ganz andere frage aber die
zentralbank ist auf jeden fall der
meinung dass es abgeschafft werden
sollte die nächste frage ist nun wie man
das anstellen soll das finanzministerium
hat die meiste zeit der nachkriegszeit
rechtlich die kontrolle gehabt wir haben
eingefahrene bürokratische strukturen
politiker und all diese kartelle und so
weiter das war das alte system nun lehrt
die geschichte dass sich ein system nur
dann grundlegend ändert wenn es eine
krise gibt
die kommission schlug vor dass die
geldpolitik zur förderung einer
historischen krise eingesetzt werden
sollte die groß genug ist um die
interessen des finanzministeriums der
politiker und der japanischen
unternehmen zu überwinden
in jedem system gibt es gruppen die
davon profitieren und daher nicht den
wunsch haben es zu ändern es gibt
wahrscheinlich kein land auf der welt
das sein wirtschaftliches soziales und
politisches system ohne eine krise in
nennenswerter weise verändert hat
es ist die krise die die bürger und
interessensgruppen von der notwendigkeit
eines wandels überzeugt
nun wie kann man das erreichen man
braucht eine krise und der beste weg sie
zu erzeugen ist eine blase denn so hält
eine niemand auf
[Musik]
die japanische zentralbank begann die
quoten für die vergabe von schaufenster
krediten deutlich zu erhöhen in den
späten 1980 er jahren lagen die
durchschnittlichen jährlichen
kreditwachstums quoten bei fast 15
prozent ein städtischer banker bemerkte
später während der spekulationsblase
wollten wir nur eine bestimmte anzahl
von krediten erhöhen aber die japanische
zentralbank wollte dass wir mehr
schaffen
dass junge leute in ihren zwanzigern und
dreißigern konnten sich auch mit
bescheidenen gehältern zweit und
drittwohnungen kaufen
der kredit bürgen der kreditboom führte
nicht nur zu einem immobilienboom
sondern auch zu einem boom auf dem
aktienmarkt
zwischen 1985 und
1989 stiegen die aktien um 240 und die
grundstückspreise um 245 prozent
[Musik]
ende der 80er jahre war der wert des
gartens der den kaiserpalast im zentrum
tokios um gibt so viel wert wie der
gesamte staat kalifornien
[Musik]
obwohl japan nur 1 26 der größe der
vereinigten staaten hat wurde sein grund
und boden mit dem vierfachen des wertes
der vereinigten staaten bewertet
[Musik]
als der marktwert eines einzigen der 23
bezirke von tokio der zentrale bezirk
skoda überstieg den wert von ganz kanada
economist wirtschaftswissenschaftler die
darauf trainiert sind an marktergebnisse
zu glauben versuchten die hohen
grundstückspreise zu rechtfertigen
einige glaubten dass die grundstücks
knappheit der grund sei
in tokios noblem geschäftsvierteln
entstanden glänzende neue
firmenzentralen der arbeitsmarkt boomte
so sehr dass ein ernsthafter mangel an
arbeitskräften befürchtet wurde
[Musik]
die unternehmen begannen studenten im
letzten studienjahr zu teuren reisen in
ferienorte einzuladen um sie zu einer
anstellung zu bewegen
[Musik]
die politiker liebten es das
finanzministerium liebte es die
steuereinnahmen stiegen die unternehmen
liebten es alles war wunderbar in der
bubble ära
dieser tag war wie ein fest wie ein
mädchen wurden ausgeführt und alles
wurde immer von den jungs und den chefs
bezahlt niemand hat öffentliche
verkehrsmittel benutzt um nach hause zu
kommen wir haben immer ein taxi genommen
[Musik]
angesichts des unaufhaltsamen anstiegs
der vermögens und aktienkurse konnten
selbst traditionelle hersteller der
versuchung nicht widerstehen sich an den
märkten zu versuchen bald bauten sie
ihre finanz und treasury abteilungen aus
um die spekulationen selbst in die hand
zu nehmen
diese hedgefonds der unternehmen bekannt
als saitek nutzten geliehenes geld um
mit immobilien und aktien zu spekulieren
der wahnsinn nahm solche ausmaße an dass
viele führende hersteller wie zb der
autohersteller nissan mehr geld mit
spekulativen investitionen als mit der
produktion von autos verdienten es
wurden buchstäblich tausende von
artikeln über das neue japanische
wirtschaftswunder geschrieben
viele wirtschaftswissenschaftler gaben
an dass die hohe und steigende
produktivität die beeindruckende
leistung der japanischen wirtschaft
erklärt
management technics bücher über
japanische management techniken wurden
zu internationalen bestsellern westliche
geschäftsleute larsen traktate aus dem
17ten jahrhundert über samurai
strategien
[Musik]
in reality in wirklichkeit hatte japans
herausragende leistungen in den 1980 er
jahren wenig mit management techniken zu
tun anstatt die kreditvergabe zu
begrenzen und zu steuern wurde die
schaufensterpolitik dazu genutzt eine
riesige blase zu erzeugen
ich habe nachforschungen angestellte und
beamte der japanischen zentralbank und
banker beide seiten auf tonband befragt
das ergebnis war dass die japanische
zentralbank ihre informelle beratung
fortsetzte tatsächlich war es die
japanische zentralbank die die banken
dazu zwang ihre kreditvergabe so stark
zu erhöhen
die japanische zentralbank wusste dass
die einzige möglichkeit für die banken
ihre kreditkarten zu erfüllen darin
bestand die unproduktive kreditvergabe
auszuweiten mit den worten eines
bankangestellten wenn es keine nachfrage
nach krediten von risikoarmen
kreditnehmern gibt und wie die quote
ausschöpfen wollen wird das risiko noch
größer
ein anderer banker wird mit den worten
zitiert dass ein nebeneffekt der regel
der window guidance bei der
kreditvergabe darin bestand dass die
banken die kreditvergabe auch dann
erhöhten wenn es keine kredit nachfrage
gab
wie alle blasen wurde auch die
japanische blase einfach durch die
rasche geldschöpfung des bankensystems
angeheizt
zwischen 1986 und
1989 leitete toshihiko fukui die banken
abteilung der japanischen zentralbank
die für die quoten für die window garten
zuständig war
als fukui von einem journalisten gefragt
wurde die kreditaufnahme nimmt schnell
zu haben sie nicht die absicht den
haaren bei den bankkrediten zuzudrehen
antwortete er da die konsequente politik
der geldpolitischen lockerung
fortgesetzt wird würde eine quantitative
kontrolle der bankkredite einen
widerspruch in sich darstellen daher
haben wir nicht die absicht eine
quantitative straffung durchzuführen
da die strukturelle anpassung der
wirtschaft schon seit geraumer zeit
andauert werden die internationalen
ungleichgewichte angegangen die
geldpolitik unterstützt dies so dass wir
die verantwortung haben die lockere
geldpolitik so lange wie möglich
fortzusetzen
daher ist es nur natürlich dass die
bankkredite ausgeweitet werden
warum haben die banken soviel geld
verliehen weil sie durch die anweisung
der japanischen zentralbank dazu
gezwungen wurden
normalerweise wählen die banken ihre
kunden aus einer großen anzahl von
kredit antragstellern aus und wähnen
einen erheblichen prozentsatz ab
doch ab 1987 hatte sich das blatt
gewendet es waren die banker die
aggressiv um potenzielle kunden warten
es gibt viele anekdoten darüber wie die
banken kredite zu günstigen zinssätzen
anboten und kunden wie straßenhändler
umworben haben
die banken ermutigten die menschen sich
geld zu leihen wenn zb ein frisch
verheiratetes paar ein haus kaufen
wollte boten ihnen die banken den
doppelten betrag den sie verlangten
die banker schätzten den grundstückswert
zunehmend überhöht ein so dass das
tatsächliche verhältnis von
grundstückswert zu kredit oft auf 300
prozent oder mehr anstieg
für die öffentlichkeit verdient ein
seltsames phänomen die leute nannten es
bald geld überschuss nur
wirtschaftswissenschaftler analysten und
diejenigen die an den finanzmärkten oder
für immobilienfirmen arbeiten wussten es
besser
sie lehnten solche vereinfachenden
analysen ab sie behaupteten dass der
anstieg der grundstückspreise weitaus
kompliziertere gründe hätte als nur
einen geld überschuss gewöhnliche
menschen verstanden einfach nicht die
feinheiten der modernen
finanztechnologie
wenn ein land zu viel geld schafft
fließt ein teil dieses geldes in form
von investitionen ins ausland ab in den
80er jahren vervielfachten sich die
japanischen kapitalströme von einem
nettozufluss von mehr als zwei
milliarden dollar im jahr 1980 auf einen
abfluss von 132 milliarden dollar im
jahr 1986
including auf vermögenswerte darunter
kunstgegenstände und andere
wertgegenstände in der ganzen welt
wurden zum ziel japanischer käufer es
gab hochkarätige käufer wie das
rockefeller center columbia pictures und
in pebble beach golf course
japanische geld erkauften sage und
schreibe 75 prozent aller 1986
versteigerten us staatsanleihen
but it is not easy aber es ist nicht
einfach für ein land einfach geld zu
drucken und dann auf eine einkaufstour
durch die welt zu gehen japan war dazu
unterlage weil die märkte seine währung
nicht abwerten
der wert der einzelnen währungen wird
von devisenhändlern festgelegt wenn die
traditionellen indikatoren auf die
devisenhändler achten die übermäßige
geldschöpfung in dem betreffenden land
nicht anzeigen kann es funktionieren
große geldmengen zu schaffen und zu
versuchen sie in ausländische währung
umzutauschen
japan hatte denselben trick angewandt
wie die vereinigten staaten in den 1950
er und 1960 er jahren als die us-banken
exzessiv dollars schufen
die amerikanischen unternehmen nutzen
dieses heiße geld um europäische
unternehmen aufzukaufen
während die vereinigten staaten durch
den goldstandard des dollars gedeckt
waren bestand japans deckung in einem
erheblichen handelsüberschuss
ein nicht bip basierter kredit ein
kredit der nicht für die produktion von
waren oder dienstleistungen verwendet
wird
rowling ein frühwarn indikator für die
entstehung eines systemischen risikos im
bankensystem ist das verhältnis von
krediten für nicht bip basierte
transaktionen zu den gesamt krediten
bis razzia in den meisten ländern die
anschließend von einer bankenkrise
heimgesucht werden steigt dieses
verhältnis deutlich an
es war derselbe prozess der die
hypothekenkredite und dem boom der
immobilienpreise in den vereinigten
staaten und dem vereinigten königreich
in den 1980 er und 2000er jahren
anheizte derselbe prozess führte auch zu
den goldenen zwanzigern in den 1920 er
jahren vergaben die banken in den usa
kredite mit aktien als sicherheiten das
prinzip bleibt dasselbe da jede bank den
aktienkurs als gegeben ansah schuf sie
neues geld mehr
geld auf dem aktienmarkt war desto mehr
mussten die aktienkurse steigen jede
bank hielt es für sicher einen
bestimmten prozentsatz des aktienwerts
als sicherheit zu akzeptieren
aber die aktionen aller banken zusammen
trieben den gesamtmarkt in die höhe
in japan stieg das gesamte grundvermögen
des privaten sektors von 14,2 billionen
yen im jahr 1969 auf 2000 billionen yen
im jahr 1989
auf seiner ersten pressekonferenz als
sechsundzwanzigster gouverneur der
japanischen zentralbank im jahr 1989
sagte yasushi mimo da die lockere
geldpolitik das problem des anstiegs der
grundstückspreise verursacht habe werde
die kreditvergabe im zusammenhang mit
immobilien nun eingeschränkt
er sah sich umsah die blase die
steigenden vermögenspreise die immer
größer werdende kluft zwischen arm und
reich das müssen wir stoppen sein name
war - und er war ein held in der presse
weil er gegen diese dumme geldpolitik
kämpfte tatsache ist jedoch dass er in
der zeit der blase stellvertretender
gouverneur und für die entstehung der
blase verantwortlich war
[Musik]
plötzlich stiegen die grundstücks und
vermögenspreise nicht mehr allein im
jahr 1990 brach der aktienmarkt um 32 1
[Musik]
dann im juli 1991 wurde die window
guidance abgeschafft dies kam für die
verantwortlichen der japanischen
zentralbank selbst überraschend die
banker waren nahezu hilflos sie
beklagten sich darüber dass sie nicht
mehr wussten wie sie ihre kreditvergabe
pläne erstellen sollten wenn in der
vergangenheit eine bestimmte filiale
sagte dass sie gerne mehr kredite
vergeben würden antworteten sie dass die
quote für die window guidance
ausgeschöpft sei
jetzt konnten sie das nicht mehr tun
[Musik]
als die banken erkannten dass der
großteil der 99 billionen yen an babbel
krediten wahrscheinlich scheitern würde
wurden sie so ängstlich dass sie nicht
nur die kreditvergabe an spekulanten
einstellten sondern auch die
kreditvergabe an alle anderen
nun es stehen düstere weihnachten für
japan bevor die börse sank am montag auf
den niedrigsten stand seit über zwei
jahren der zusammenbruch eines der
größten lebensmittelhändler japans in
der vergangenen woche war der neunte
eines börsennotierten unternehmens in
diesem jahr
[Musik]
mehr als fünf millionen japaner verloren
ihre arbeit und fanden keine andere
beschäftigung
selbstmord wurde zur häufigsten
todesursachen bei männern im alter
zwischen 20 und 44 jahren
[Musik]
die zeitungen berichteten fast täglich
über menschen die sich erhängten oder
verschwanden
[Musik]
zwischen 1990 und 2003 fiel der
aktienmarkt um 80 prozent die
grundstückspreise in den großstädten
fielen um bis zu 84 prozent einige
ökonomen schienen erleichtert zu sein
der abschwung war ein beweis dafür dass
japans wirtschaftssystem doch nicht so
erfolgreich war
unterdessen sagte der gouverneur der
japanischen zentralbank yasushi milieu
das sich dank dieser rezession jeder der
notwendigkeit einer wirtschaftlichen
umgestaltung bewusst wird
[Musik]
das finanzministerium das die zinssätze
für das wichtigste politische instrument
hielten übte druck auf die zentralbank
aus die zinssätze zu senken bis der
offizielle zinssatz 0,1 prozent
erreichte
die meisten wirtschaftswissenschaftler
sagten eine wirtschaftliche erholung
voraus
[Musik]
barth des bdv rico noch trotz der
häufigen behauptungen in der
finanzpresse und von den zentralbanken
das niedrigere zinsen das wachstum
ankurbeln und höhere zinsen das wachstum
bremsen gibt es keine empirischen belege
für diesen zusammenhang
[Musik]
japanische und amerikanische
geschäftsleute treffen sich hier mit
einem plädoyer der japanischen
unternehmen für einen niedrigeren yen
nur sechs prozent der japanischen
exporteure können bei einem dollar kurs
von weniger als 100 yen gewinne erzielen
im durchschnitt müssen sie die
amerikanische währung auf über 117 yen
anheben um die gewinnschwelle zu
erreichen
das finanzministerium partie zentralbank
große mengen an yen zu verkaufen und us
dollar zu kaufen damit der wechselkurs
des yen sinken und die exporte steigen
würden
wir alle wissen dass die beiden das
finanzministerium und die zentralbank
nicht gut miteinander auskommen und was
diesen monat wieder passiert ist ist
dass die zentralbank ihre eigenen
interventionen sterilisiert hat um genau
zu sein die interventionen die vom
finanzministerium angeordnet wurden
das finanzministerium weist die
japanische zentralbank an
us-staatsanleihen im wert von etwa 20
milliarden zu kaufen doch die japanische
zentralbank sterilisiert dies das heißt
sie entzieht der wirtschaft geld um
diesen kauf zu finanzieren
die meisten forscher sind sich einig
dass sterilisierte
devisenmarktinterventionen nicht
funktionieren die zentralbank die
realisiert erneut deshalb funktioniert
es nicht deshalb ist der yen stark
geblieben
[Musik]
kleine zentralbank an geld aus der
wirtschaft abziehen indem sie ihre
vermögenswerte verkauft genauso wie sie
der wirtschaft geld zuführen kann indem
sie vermögenswerte kauft
wenn zentralbanken vermögenswerte kaufen
und verkaufen erhöhen oder verringern
sie die in der wirtschaft zirkulierende
geldmenge
die beamten der japanischen zentralbank
ignorierten dies und behauptete
stattdessen dass dieser strukturwandel
oder diese reform kurzfristig
deflationäre kräfte erzeugen kann aber
nach einer weile eine viel effizientere
wirtschaft hervorbringen wird
independiente service unabhängige
beobachter meinten die binnennachfrage
müsse durch staatliche ausgaben
angekurbelt werden dann würde auch die
kreditnachfrage steigen
ein jahrzehnt lang befolgte die
regierung diesen rat und steigerte die
staatsverschuldung auf ein historisches
niveau
zwischen 1992 und 2002 wurden 146
billionen yen ausgegeben
richard werner ist chefvolkswirt bei
jordan fleming securities in tokio er
teilt uns jetzt seine ansichten zur
entwicklung der japanischen wirtschaft
mit die regierung gab mit der rechten
hand geld aus indem sie der wirtschaft
geld zu führte aber die
mittelbeschaffung erfolgte über den
anleihemarkt und deshalb entnahm sie mit
der linken hand das selbe geld aus der
wirtschaft es gab keinen anstieg der
gesamt kaufkraft
bis 2011 für die japans
staatsverschuldung 230 prozent des bip
erreichen die höchste der welt
[Musik]
dem finanzministerium gingen die
möglichkeiten aus beobachter begannen
das ministerium für die rezession
verantwortlich zu machen und begannen
auf die stimmen zu hören die behaupteten
die rezession sei auf das japanische
wirtschaftssystem zurückzuführen
aber wie schwierig wäre es gewesen die
probleme der faulen kredite im
bankensektor und der deflation zu lösen
es stellte sich heraus dass dies gar
nicht so schwierig gewesen wäre das
finanzsystem ist immer ein teufelskreis
es gibt kein kreditwachstum also gibt es
kein wirtschaftswachstum also gibt es
keinen kreditwachstum also gibt es kein
wirtschaftswachstum nun es gibt eine
sache die dieses zirkuläre argument
durchbrechen kann und das ist die
zentralbank die aufgabe der zentralbank
in dieser situation ist es geld zu
drucken
was wir jetzt brauchen sind radikalere
maßnahmen und es gibt einige
schmerzhafte aber es gibt auch
schmerzlose die zentralbank könnte zum
beispiel einfach alle faulen schulden
zum nennwert aufkaufen japan hätte dann
die stärksten banken der welt
um den bankensektor zu retten kann eine
zentralbank die vollen finanzaktiva der
banken mit neu geschaffenen geld auf
kaufen und ihnen den nennwert für die
aktive geben die oft deutlich weniger
wert sind so hat es die japanische
zentralbank nach dem krieg getan
alternativ könnte geld an die banken
transferiert werden indem man ihnen mit
halt große gewinne zu erzielen eine
möglichkeit dies zu erreichen besteht
darin dass die zentralbank einen markt
in die enge treibt und so eine mini
blase in einem bestimmten markt schafft
in denen die banken stark investieren
was ihnen große gewinne beschert
dies ist eine relativ gängige methode
der zentralbanken um ihren
bankensystemen zu helfen
andere vorschläge beinhalten maßnahmen
zur einführung von null risiko
kreditnehmern bei banken oder die
einführung von änderungen in der
rechnungslegung die ihre bilanzen
verbessern
in japan argumentierten die behörden und
die zentralbank wie fast zwei jahrzehnte
später auch die westlichen mächte dass
der steuerzahler die rechnung bezahlen
sollte
[Musik]
die ja wie sie sich vielleicht erinnern
hat die regierung im märz letzten jahres
etwa 15 großen japanischen
finanzinstituten eine große summe geld
zugeführt und wir waren eines von ihnen
das hat uns geholfen faule kredite
abzuschreiben und unsere kapitalbasis zu
stärken damit wir bereits in kredite zu
vergeben
[Musik]
steuergelder wurden zur
rekapitalisierung von banken verwendet
es gibt jedoch keine beweise dafür dass
die steuerzahler für die probleme der
banken verantwortlich waren daher haben
solche maßnahmen wahrscheinlich ein
moralisches risiko geschaffen
die geldmenge wird durch den
nettozuwachs der geldschöpfung der
banken und der zentralbank bestimmt wenn
das moralische risiko vorschreibt dass
der bankensektor nicht gerettet werden
sollte können deflation und rezession
von der zentralbank immer noch vermieden
werden zu diesem zweck kann die
zentralbank die geldmenge erhöhen
eine zentralbank an die geldmenge in
einer volkswirtschaft jederzeit und
unbegrenzt erhöhen indem sie einfach
vermögenswerte vom privaten sektor kauft
und mit neu geschaffenen krediten
bezahlt die zentralbank hätte zum
beispiel immobilien kaufen und in
öffentliche parks umwandeln können
und hier besteht die möglichkeit drei
probleme auf einen schlag zu lösen die
wirtschaft braucht geldschöpfung die
banken müssen ihre faulen kredite
loswerden und der immobiliensektor
braucht einige transaktionen was man tun
kann ist die zentralbank geld drucken zu
lassen den banken das land abzukaufen es
in parks umzuwandeln und damit auch ein
weiteres problem zu lösen die
lebensqualität in japan
selbst wenn die zentralbank diese parks
später zu einem bruchteil der kosten
verkauft hätte hätte sie immer noch geld
verdient weil es eine zentralbank nichts
kostet das geld überhaupt erst zu
schaffen eine weitere möglichkeit geld
in die wirtschaft zu pumpen ist die
quantitative lockerung
trotz all dieser möglichkeiten weigerte
sich die japanische zentralbank zu jedem
zeitpunkt maßnahmen zu ergreifen die die
krise hätten lösen können
als ich 1992
1993 als gastwissenschaftler bei der
japanischen zentralbank war war ich
davon überzeugt dass diese rezession
wirklich schlimm werden würde also
fragte ich jeden mitarbeiter der
japanischen zentralbank der mit mir
sprechen wollte warum sie nicht mehr
geld drucken ich traf eine person die
sehr offen darüber sprach und sie sagte
richard natürlich hätten wir mehr geld
drucken können wir hätten einen
aufschwung herbeiführen können aber dann
hätte sich nichts geändert die
wirtschaftsstruktur hätte sich nicht
verändert damals war ich noch nicht
bereit zu glauben dass die zentralbank
die rezession ernsthaft in die länge zog
um strukturelle veränderungen zu
erreichen die mir ein wenig zu wild
erschienen
finanzminister masayoshi son die
zentralbank gewandt und sie gebeten die
deflation zu stoppen oder zumindest zu
bekämpfen
die zentralbank widersetzte sich
konsequent den aufforderungen der
regierung des finanzministers und des
premierministers mehr geld zu drucken um
die wirtschaft anzukurbeln und die lange
rezession zu beenden
times zeitweise reduzierte die
japanische zentralbank sogar aktiv die
in der wirtschaft zirkulierende
geldmenge was die rezession noch
verschlimmerte
[Musik]
die argumente der japanischen
zentralbank waren immer die gleichen
nämlich dass die schuld in der
wirtschaftsstruktur japans liegt
central banks dorf mitarbeiter der
zentralbank argumentierten sogar dass
eine erhebliche geldpolitische lockerung
schaden anrichten könnte indem sie eine
weitere verzögerung des fortschritts der
strukturellen anpassung bewirke
die früheren japanischen führer der
nachkriegszeit wussten dass ihr eine
kriegswirtschaft betrieben aber sie
wollten aus politischen gründen nicht
darüber sprechen
wo propaganda die propaganda botschaft
des kalten krieges lautete dass das
japan der nachkriegszeit ein politisches
und wirtschaftliches system nach
amerikanischem vorbild übernommen hatte
dass sie nicht bereit waren die wahrheit
zu sagen name die frühen nachkriegs
führer ihr intimes wissen über die
ursprünge von japans wirtschaftswunder
mit ins grab in den 1980 er und 1990 er
jahren herrschte eine generation von
bürokraten und politikern die den wahren
charakter und zweck der wirtschaft ihres
landes nicht verstanden
[Musik]
sie kommt eine ganze generation
japanischer wirtschaftswissenschaftler
wurde in die vereinigten staaten
geschickt um dort einen doktortitel und
einen mba abschluss in
wirtschaftswissenschaften nach
amerikanischem vorbild zu erwerben
classical economics die neoklassische
wirtschaftswissenschaft davon ausgeht
dass es nur eine art von
wirtschaftssystem gibt nämlich
uneingeschränkte freie märkte in denen
aktionäre und zentralbanker das sagen
haben haben viele japanische
wirtschaftswissenschaftler schnell die
argumente der us amerikanischen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler
nachgeplappert
[Musik]
die usa und japan haben am dienstag
zweitägige gespräche über versicherungs
regulierungen abgeschlossen die
deregulierung des primär sektors ist
notwendig um die festgefahrenen
interessen der großen
versicherungsgesellschaften sowohl der
lebens als auch sachversicherer und die
bürokratie des finanzministeriums zu
überwinden
sie müssen vor dem 15 dezember eine
einigung erzielen denn nach diesem datum
haben die usa mit handelssanktionen
gedroht ein wichtiger schritt den
analysten erwarten ist die verbriefung
von immobilien aber wird das paket
ausreichen mehr dazu im gespräch mit
richard werner um eine sinnvolle
verbriefung zu erreichen brauchen wir
eine deregulierung und das ist bereits
der antwort auf ihre frage um eine
deregulierung zu erreichen müssen sie
die macht des finanzministeriums
beschneiden und offensichtlich hat sich
das ministerium dem widersetzt
in den 1980 er jahren wurden personen
die sich mit einer visitenkarte des
renommierten finanzministeriums
vorstellen konnten verehrt und
respektiert doch mitte der 1990 er jahre
hatte sich die einstellung geändert und
für die meisten beobachter gab es kaum
noch zweifel daran dass das
finanzministerium die rezession
verursacht hatte
vor den toren des ministeriums kam es
häufig zu demonstrationen von bürgern
die über die handlungen der bürokraten
empört waren
in allen 19 anfang 1998 führte die
staatsanwaltschaft zum ersten mal eine
razzia im mächtigsten japanischen
ministerium durch
sowohl die banken als auch ihre
aufsichtsbehörden wurden für ihr
vorgehen heftig kritisiert die skandale
warfen ein schlaglicht auf einige der
informellen verbindungen die zwischen
beamten des finanzministeriums und
bänkern bestanden viele bankangestellte
und sogar einige ministerialbeamte
wurden verhaftet und ins gefängnis
gesteckt und mehrere begingen selbstmord
banker massa wieder zentralbanker
maserati shirakawa erklärt hatte es ist
nicht einfach den institutionellen
rahmen zu ändern und strukturelle
reformen zu fördern da dies
notwendigerweise die interessen aller
beteiligten wirtschaftsakteure berührt
ein stellvertretender gouverneur der
japanischen zentralbank sagte dass die
zentralbank vor dem großen dilemma steht
dass die lockerung der geldpolitik zu
einer abschwächung der unmittelbaren
risiken führen würde was wiederum eine
verzögerung der endgültigen lösungen zur
folge hätte
91 ab mitte der 1990 er jahre begann die
regierung einen großteil der
machtstruktur des finanzministeriums
abzubauen die zentralbank hingegen
konnte ihren einfluss erheblich ausbauen
sie haben erst kürzlich geschrieben sie
haben keinen zweifel daran dass die
zentralbank die japanische zentralbank
vom finanzministerium losgelöst und
unabhängig werden wird so dass sie mit
anderen zentralbanken gleich gestellt
wird warum sind sie so sicher
wie im grunde genommen hat das
finanzministerium dass zumindest die
zentralbank rechtlich kontrollierte jede
glaubwürdigkeit verloren das
finanzministerium wird für die
entstehung der blase für die lange
rezession und für viele andere probleme
die wir in letzter zeit in japan hatten
verantwortlich gemacht die japanische
zentralbank hingegen stand nicht im
rampenlicht der öffentlichen kritik und
nutzt dies nun um zu sagen nun das
finanzministerium war schlecht wir
brauchen jetzt unabhängigkeit
richard vielen dank ich habe mit richard
werner gesprochen dem chefvolkswirt von
john fleming securities in tokio
so nahmen kurz nach seinem ausscheiden
aus dem amt des gouverneurs der
japanischen zentralbank im jahr 1994
begann milano eine kampagne mit reden
von verschiedenen verbänden und
interessensgruppen er setzte sich für
eine änderung des gesetzes über die
zentralbank ein
mit seiner argumentation bestand darin
auf subtile weise anzudeuten dass das
finanzministerium die japanische
zentralbank zu einer falschen politik
gedrängt hatte um solche probleme in
zukunft zu vermeiden müsse der
japanischen zentralbank volle rechtliche
unabhängigkeit gewährt werden
according to me die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbanken zum jene entspreche der
menschlichen weisheit die sich in der
geschichte entwickelt habe im jahr 1998
wurde die geldpolitik in die hände der
nun unabhängigen japanischen zentralbank
gelegt
sie sagen also dass sowohl politiker als
auch ökonomen mehr druck auf die
japanische zentralbank ausüben sollten
mehr geld zu schaffen aber viele
kritiker werden sagen dass das ein
eingriff in die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbank ist was halten sie davon
das ist genau richtig das ist ein
eingriff in die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbanken und das ist genau das was
wir brauchen
[Musik]
die zahlreichen skandale die auf das
platzen der blase erfolgten brachten
1995 auch das system der ein parteien
herrschaft der liberaldemokratischen
partei zu fall
im alten system konkurrierten die
politiker nicht miteinander indem sie
unterschiedliche politics dealer
vorschlugen die politik wurde von den
bürokraten gemacht und die politiker
konzentrierten sich lediglich darauf
lokale wählerschaften mit öffentlichen
bauprojekten zu beschwichtigen
im oktober 1997 gingen zum ersten mal in
der nachkriegsgeschichte
alle politischen initiativen zur
ankurbelung der wirtschaft von
politikern und nicht von bürokraten aus
wenn in die tausende anfang 2001 wurde
dann ein neuer typ politiker an die
macht gebracht
juni wurde premierminister in bezug auf
seine popularität und seine politik wird
er oft mit margaret thatcher und ronald
reagan verglichen seine botschaft war
einfach kein aufschwung ohne
strukturreformen
[Musik]
auf dem genfer gipfel im juli 2001 sagte
er manche sagen der aufschwung kommt
zuerst ohne reformen aber sobald sich
die wirtschaft erholt schwindet der
wille zu reformen deshalb werde ich nach
den wahlen an dem plan festhalten dass
es ohne strukturreformen kein wachstum
geben wird
im laufe des jahres 2001 wurde die
botschaft dass das ohne strukturreformen
kein wirtschaftswachstum gibt fast
täglich über die fernsehbildschirme der
nation verbreitet
die länder des g 7 gipfel druck auf
japan aus strukturreformen durchzuführen
in korea gab es unruhen aber dann
beschloss die regierung große
konglomerate zu zerschlagen
jetzt erholt sich die wirtschaft des
landes nun ist es an der zeit dass japan
struktur reformen durchführt
[Musik]
jetzt glaubt jeder dass wir strukturelle
veränderungen brauchen dass wir den
kapitalismus japanischer prägung
abschaffen müssen um einen aufschwung zu
erreichen es scheint dass wir alles
ausprobiert haben und nichts hat
funktioniert also muss das japanische
wirtschaftssystem schuld sein daher
sollten wir es besser loswerden
[Musik]
shifting economics ist japan stellte
sein wirtschaftssystem auf eine
marktwirtschaft nach amerikanischem
vorbild rum und das bedeutete auch dass
das zentrum der wirtschaft von den
banken auf die aktienmärkte verlagert
wurde
anleger dazu zu bewegen ihr geld von den
banken abzuziehen und in den riskanten
aktienmarkt zu investieren hoben die
reformer die garantie für alle
bankeinlagen auf und schufen
gleichzeitig steuerliche anreize für
aktieninvestitionen
mit der ausbreitung des shareholder
kapitalismus nach amerikanischem vorbild
stiegen die arbeitslosigkeit die
einkommens und vermögens unterschiede
sowie selbstmorde und gewaltverbrechen
erheblich an
im jahr 2002 verstärkte die japanische
zentralbank dann ihre bemühungen die
bankbilanzen zu verschlechtern und die
banken zu zwingen ihre kreditnehmer
zwang zu vollstrecken bis dahin hatte
sich accor yanagida war minister für
finanzdienstleistungen gegen den von der
japanischen zentralbank inspirierten
vorschlag gewehrt den banken
steuergelder zuzuführen sie faktisch zu
verstaatlichen ihre verwaltung zu
übernehmen und dieser macht zu nutzen um
kredite von unternehmen einzufordern was
zu zahlreichen insolvenzen von
großunternehmen führte
yanagida war wurde daraufhin vom
premierminister entlassen und durch
heese takenaka ersetzt takenaka war ein
befürworter des plans der japanischen
zentralbank die zahl der
zwangsvollstreckungen von kreditnehmern
zu erhöhen
minister takenaka versuchte eine politik
umzusetzen die die bilanzen der banken
drastisch wechte um sie verstaatlichen
zu können
er nannte eine taskforce zur überwachung
der banken politik der zwei ehemalige
mitarbeiter der japanischen zentralbank
angehörten einer von ihnen taktische
kimura forderte sofort die einführung
von änderungen in der rechnungslegung
die die bilanzen der banken
verschlechtern und eine verstaatlichung
unumgänglich machen würden
doro moritz ein bekannter
wirtschaftswissenschaftler in tokio
argumentierte eindringlich dass der von
der japanischen zentralbank inspirierte
vorschlag von takenaka nicht viele
einheimische nutznießer hätte sondern
stattdessen vor allem us amerikanischen
geyer fonds zugute käme die auf den
aufkauf notleidender vermögenswerte
spezialisiert sind
dieser fand diese kaya fonds waren mit
dem problem konfrontiert dass trotz über
200.000 konkursen nur wenige unternehmen
die groß genug waren um für die gala
fonds von interesse zu sein bankrott
gingen
als kimura und fukui ihre unterstützung
für den insolvenzplan bekundeten leitete
erste rein privates unternehmen das bei
der verbriefung von notleidenden
vermögenswerten berät und letzterer war
berater der wall street investmentfirma
goldman sachs einem der größten
betreiber von gaia fonds weltweit
sein mentor hermlin und sein mentor
heerma war sie ahnen ist das sind einige
der prinzen des yen um die es in dem
buch geht sie haben in den 80er jahren
und auch in den 90er jahren immer wieder
gesagt was ist das ziel der geldpolitik
es ist die wirtschaftsstruktur zu
verändern und wie stellt man das an nun
man braucht eine krise und genau dafür
haben sie gesagt
wir haben keine zeit mehr ich muss sie
leider unterbrechen ich arbeite für eine
der großen stadt banken ich war früher
für die kreditvergabe an die japanische
zentralbank zuständig während der bubble
ära wurde uns von der japanischen
zentralbank alle drei monate mitgeteilt
um wie viel die kredite erhöht werden
mussten die zuteilung der window
guidance der japanischen zentralbank war
ein befehl
die ursache der blase war die window
guidance und sie wurde auf anweisung der
japanischen zentralbank durchgeführt
die abteilung die bei der japanischen
zentralbank für die quoten für die
windows zuständig war hieß banking
department
und wer war der verantwortliche dafür
der mann an der spitze dieser bank
abteilung während der blase von 86 bis
89 kilo fukui hervor der derzeitige
gouverneur der japanischen zentralbank
ist der mann der die blase geschaffen
hat
als fukui gouverneur der japanischen
zentralbank wurde sagte er während das
starke wachstumsmodell zerstört wird
baue ich ein modell auf das in die neue
ära passt
sie haben in jeder hinsicht erfolg
gehabt wenn man sich die liste ihrer
ziele anschaut haben sie alle diese
ziele erreicht das finanzministerium
zerstören es auflösen eine unabhängige
aufsichtsbehörde einrichten die
unabhängigkeit der japanischen
zentralbank selbst durch eine änderung
des japanischen zentralbank gesetzes
erreichen und tiefgreifende strukturelle
veränderungen in der wirtschaft
herbeiführen indem sie sich von der
produktion auf dienstleistungen
verlagern sich öffnen deregulieren
liberalisieren privatisieren all das
in den 1920 er jahren in japans
wirtschaft in vielerlei hinsicht der
heutigen us wirtschaft mit hartem
wettbewerb aggressiven einstellungen und
entlassungen
übernahmeschlachten zwischen großen
unternehmen weniger bürokratischen
kontrollen starken aktionären die hohe
dividenden forderten und einer
unternehmens- finanzierung durch die
märkte nicht durch die banken
während der gesamten nachkriegszeit war
japans wirtschaft jedoch das gegenteil
stark reguliert mit kartellen die den
wettbewerb einschränken bankfinanzierung
und überkreuzbeteiligungen die die
machte aktionäre einschränkten keine
übernahmen und ein eingefrorener
arbeitsmarkt mit lebenslanger
beschäftigung und dienstalter vergütung
etwas claim traktor ende recession es
wurde behauptet dass japan um die
rezession zu beenden und die leistung zu
verbessern vom wohlfahrt kapitalismus
zurück zum shareholder kapitalismus
wechseln müsse es bleibt jedoch unklar
warum ein land das einen beständigen und
erheblichen handelsbilanz überschuss
erzielt hat sein wirtschaftssystem
ändern muss um wettbewerbsfähiger zu
sein
japan war nicht die einzige
leistungsstarke volkswirtschaft in asien
die in den 1990 er jahren in die tiefste
rezession seit der großen depression
gerät
im jahr 1997 konnten die währungen der
südostasiatischen tigerstaaten keinen
festen wechselkurs zum us dollar
aufrecht erhalten sie brachen innerhalb
eines jahres um 60 bis 80 prozent ein
die ursachen für diesen absturz reichen
bis in das jahr 1993 zurück
in jenem jahr führten die asiatischen
tigerstaaten südkorea thailand und
indonesien eine aggressive
lockerungspolitik im kapitalverkehr und
internationale bankdienstleistungen ein
die es dem unternehmens- und
bankensektor ermöglichten großzügig
kredite im ausland aufzunehmen es war
das erste mal in der nachkriegszeit dass
kreditnehmer dies tun konnten
in wirklichkeit bestand für die
asiatischen tigerstaaten keine
notwendigkeit sich geld im ausland zu
leihen das gesamte für inländische
investitionen erforderliche geld konnte
im eigenen land geschaffen werden der
druck zur liberalisierung der
kapitalströme kam in der tat von außen
seit anfang der 1990 er jahre hatten der
iwf die welthandelsorganisation und das
us-finanzministerium
lobbyarbeit in diesen ländern betrieben
um inländischen unternehmen die
kreditaufnahme im ausland zu ermöglichen
sie argumentierten dass die
neoklassische wirtschaftslehre bewiesen
habe dass freie märkte und freier
kapitalverkehr das wirtschaftswachstum
steigern
nach der die regulierung der
kapitalkosten machten sich die
zentralbanken daran unwiderstehlicher
anreize für inländische unternehmen zu
schaffen kredite im ausland aufzunehmen
sie verteuerten die kreditaufnahme in
der eigenen landeswährung gegenüber der
kreditaufnahme in us dollar
die inländischen zinssätze waren hoch
sie waren höher als die zinssätze des us
dollars und der wechselkurs für
praktisch fix
es waren die regierung und die
zentralbank die gesagt haben wir werden
den wechselkurs beibehalten das stimmt
die zentralbanken thailand und andere
ostasiatische länder widersetzten sich
der wechselkurs anpassung und versuchten
ein zeichen dafür zu setzen den
wechselkurs schützen zu wollen
central banks in the public statement
die zentralbanken betonten in ihren
öffentlichen erklärungen dass sie feste
wechselkurse zum us-dollar beibehalten
würden so dass die kreditnehmer nicht
befürchten mussten in ihrer
landeswährung mehr zurück zu zahlen als
ursprünglich aufgenommen hatten
teils sich in thailand war ich war auf
einer emission als externer berater ging
ich direkt zur bank von thailand und
fragte gibt es irgendwelche informellen
kreditrichtlinien
sie waren überrascht dass sich diese
frage stellte aufgrund meines studiums
in japan dachte ich dass es vielleicht
etwas ähnliches gebe und es war ein
junger mitarbeiter der sich vielleicht
der politischen zusammenhänge nicht
bewusst war der sagte ja ja wir haben
sollen kredit planung schema
die banken wurden angewiesen die
kreditvergabe zu erhöhen sie sahen sich
jedoch mit einer geringeren
kreditnachfrage aus den produktiven
sektoren der wirtschaft konfrontiert da
diese unternehmen anreiz erhalten hatten
lieber kredite im ausland aufzunehmen
sie mussten daher ihre kreditvergabe auf
risikoreichere kreditnehmer ausweiten
im boxring die importe begannen zu
schrumpfen weil die zentralbanken
vereinbart hatten ihre währungen an den
us dollar zu binden
die volkswirtschaften wurden weniger
wettbewerbsfähig aber ihre
leistungsbilanz blieb aufgrund der im
ausland ausgegebenen kredite die in der
zahlungsbilanz statistik als exporte
zählen stabil
spekulanten damit begannen den
thailändischen baht den koreanischen won
und die indonesische rupie zu verkaufen
reagierten die jeweiligen zentralbanken
mit vergeblichen versuchen die bindung
aufrecht zu erhalten bis sie praktisch
ihre gesamten devisenreserven
aufgebraucht hatten
dies gab ausländischen kreditgebern
reichlich gelegenheit sie ihr geld zu
überhöhten wechselkursen abzuziehen
die zentralbanken wussten dass sie wenn
den ländern die devisenreserven
ausgingen den iwf einschalten mussten um
einen zahlungsausfall zu vermeiden und
wenn der iwf erst einmal da war wussten
den zentralbanken was diese in
washington ansässige institution
verlangen würde denn ihre forderungen
waren in solchen fällen in den
vergangenen drei jahrzehnten immer die
gleichen die zentralbanken sollten
unabhängig werbe
am 16 juli flog der thailändische
finanzminister nach tokio um japan um
ein rettungspaket zu bitten
damals verfügte japan über devisen
reserven in höhe von 213 milliarden
us-dollar mehr als die gesamten mittel
des iwf
man war bereit zu helfen aber washington
stoppte die initiative japans jede
lösung für die sich entwickelnde
asienkrise musste von washington über
den iwf kommen
nach zwei monaten spekulativer angriffe
hat die thailändische regierung den bart
freigegeben
wo werden der internationale
währungsfonds hat den angeschlagenen
volkswirtschaften von thailand
indonesien und südkorea bisher fast 120
milliarden dollar zugesagt
medias unmittelbar nach ihrer ankunft in
den krisengeschüttelten ländern
richteten die iwf teams büros sind in
zentralbanken ein von wo aus sie regeln
vorgaben die sich wie eine kapitulation
forderung an
herten.de wie er forderte eine reihe von
maßnahmen darunter die einschränkung der
kreditvergabe durch die zentralbank und
die banken umfangreiche
gesetzesänderungen und eine drastische
anhebung der zinssätze
als investor aus als die zinssätze
stiegen konnten erste risikoreiche
kreditnehmer ihre darlehen nicht mehr
bedienen die bankensysteme thailands
koreas und indonesiens die mit großen
mengen uneinbringlicher forderungen
belastet waren waren praktisch bankrott
even though reißt selbst ansonsten
gesunde unternehmen begannen unter der
sich ausweitenden kreditklemme zu leiden
die unternehmensinsolvenzen stiegen
sprunghaft an die arbeitslosigkeit stieg
auf den höchsten stand seit den 1930 er
jahren
die rolle des fonds bei der rettung
angeschlagener länder ist heftig
umstritten einige haben den iwf sogar
beschuldigt die wirtschaftkrise in asien
zu verschärfen
wenn sie unsere wirtschaft untergraben
müssen werden sie das tun nur um zu
beweisen dass sie im recht sind der iwf
war keine große hilfe
der iwf wusste genau welche folgen sein
vorgehen haben würde im falle koreas
wurden sogar detaillierte aber nicht
veröffentlichte studien durchgeführt in
denen berechnet wurde wie viele
koreanische unternehmen bankrott gehen
würden wenn die zinssätze um fünf
prozentpunkte gestiegen
das erste abkommen des iwf mit korea
verlangte eine erhöhung der zinssätze um
genau fünf prozentpunkte
die politik des iwf zielt eindeutig
nicht darauf ab einen wirtschaftlichen
aufschwung in den asiatischen ländern zu
erreichen sie verfolgen eine ganz andere
agenda nämlich die veränderung der
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
sozialen systeme in diesen ländern und
wirklich die iwf geschäfte verhindern
dass die betroffenen länder wie korea
und thailand einen aufschwung erleben
interessant sie sagen dass es die krise
verschlimmere und sie behaupten dass der
iwf eine heimliche agenda hatte diese
agenda ist kein geheimnis denn der iwf
verlangt ganz offen dass die betroffenen
asiatischen länder die gesetze ändern
damit ausländische interessenten alles
kaufen können von banken bis zu land und
in der tat können die bankensysteme laut
iwf die nur mit ausländischem geld ihr
kapital erhöhen dabei ist das gar nicht
notwendig denn solange diese länder
zentralbanken haben können sie einfach
geld drucken und die bankensysteme
rekapitalisieren dafür braucht man kein
geld aus dem ausland es geht also
eindeutig darum asien für ausländische
interessenten zu öffnen
die iwf verlangte dass in
schwierigkeiten geratener banken nicht
gerettet sondern geschlossen und als
notleidende aktiva billig verkauft
werden häufig an große us
investmentbanken
eine gute nachricht aus thailand ist
dass sie einige große vermögenswerte von
56 finanzunternehmen versteigern werden
sollten ihrer meinung nach einige der
eigentümer der 56 finanzunternehmen die
möglichkeit haben ihre vermögenswerte
zurückzukaufen
in den meisten fällen wurde in den vom
iwf diktierte absichtserklärungen
ausdrücklich festgelegt dass die banken
an ausländische investoren verkauft
werden mussten
und lassen sie mich in dieser hinsicht
betonen dass diese reformprogramme der
schlüssel der absolute schlüssel zur
wiederherstellung der finanziellen
stabilität sind
zum ersten mal überhaupt hat südkorea
fünf banken geschlossen und damit einen
wichtigen schritt zur erfüllung des iwf
mandats getan
die zahl der geschäftsbanken ist
zurückgegangen und schließungen fusionen
und übernahmen und ausländische
strategische investoren mission jetzt
mit was eine bemerkenswerte veränderung
ist
in esche
rodman drogen ist bayer in asien waren
staatlich organisierte rettungsaktionen
zur rettung maroder finanzinstitute
untersagt doch als ein jahr später eine
ähnliche krise in amerika ausbrach
reagierten dieselben institute anders
der connector based herrn spahn
der in connecticut ansässige hedgefonds
long term capital management der nur
vermögende privatanleger und
institutionen als kunden akzeptierte
hatte seinen kunden kapital von fünf
milliarden dollar um mehr als das
25-fache gehebelt und sich dafür von den
banken dieser welt mehr als 100
milliarden dollar gelingen
ihre verluste die banken mit
runterzuziehen drohten die ihre kredite
gewährt hatten und eine systemische
bankenkrise drohte die das us
finanzsystem und die us wirtschaft
gefährden konnte organisierte die
federal reserve eine kartell ähnliche
rettungsaktion in dem sie sich auf die
wall street und internationale banken
stützte um mittel bei zu steuern mit
denen ein zahlungsausfall vermieden
werden konnte
sie haben recht washington und new york
schienen da mit zweierlei maß zu messen
kurz nachdem sie allen asiatischen
ländern gesagt hatten dass es keine
rettungsaktionen für finanzinstitutionen
geben würde wurde für long term capital
management ein hedgefond new york der
fast pleite ging plötzlich eine
rettungsaktion organisiert was im
widerspruch zu dem stand was sie den
asiatischen ländern gerade erst gesagt
hatten aber sie sagten dass keine
öffentlichen gelder für ltcm verwendet
wurden aber das treffen fand bekanntlich
innerhalb der federal reserve statt
warum sollten die vereinigten staaten im
namen des freien marktes forderungen an
fremde nationen stellen wenn sie nicht
die absicht haben dieselben regeln
innerhalb ihrer eigenen grenzen
durchzusetzen die beispiele der
japanischen und der asiatischen krise
zeigen wie krisen konstruiert werden
können um die umverteilung von
wirtschaftlichen eigentum zu erleichtern
und rechtliche strukturelle und
politische veränderungen durchzusetzen
heute sind ähnliche ereignisse in der
eurozone zu beobachten
konnten die juroren die länder des euro
währungsfonds haben ihr recht auf eine
nationale währung verloren und die macht
an die europäische zentralbank abgegeben
bei mir hier im studio ist richard
werner er ist professor an der
universität southampton richard war
berater der japanischen zentralbank und
des finanzministeriums am ende der
bubble lehrer an den 90er jahren was
raten sie der ezb die morgen tag was
würden sie ihm sagen
nun auch hier sollte sie sich mehr auf
das kreditvolumen als auf die zinssätze
konzentrieren die ezb muss aus ihren
fehlern der vergangenheit lernen denn
ich glaube sie hat die kreditschöpfung
nicht sorgfältig genug überwacht in
spanien und irland hatten wir unter der
aufsicht der ezb eine massive
kreditausweitung der leitzins in der
eurozone ist natürlich überall gleich
aber das volumen der kredite ist sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt einen
einheitlichen zinssatz für die gesamte
eurozone aber 2002 wies die ezb die
deutsche bundesbank an die
kreditschöpfung um den größten betrag in
ihrer geschichte zu reduzieren und sie
wie es die irische zentralbank an geld
zu drucken als gäbe es kein morgen
was wird nun also kommen gleicher
leitzins gleiches wachstum nein
rezession in deutschland aufschwung in
irland was sagt ihnen das welche
variable kreditschöpfung
von personen vor ab 2004 stiegen unter
der aufsicht der ezb die bank kredite in
irland griechenland portugal und spanien
um über 20 prozent pro jahr an und die
immobilienpreise schossen in die höhe
als die bankkredite zurückgingen brachen
die immobilienpreise ein bauträger
gingen pleite und die bankensysteme von
irland portugal spanien und griechenland
wurden zahlungsunfähig
wsb ezb hätte diese blasen verhindern
können ebenso wie sie die darauf
folgenden banken und wirtschaft krisen
hätte beenden können doch sie weigerte
sich dies zu tun bevor nicht größere
politische zugeständnisse gemacht wurden
wie beispielsweise die übertragung der
steuer und haushalts befugnisse von den
einzelnen souveränen staaten auf die
europäische union
spain and greet sowohl in spanien als
auch in griechenland ist die
jugendarbeitslosigkeit auf 50 prozent
gestiegen so dass viele jugendliche
gezwungen sind sich im ausland arbeit zu
suchen griechische ärzte für deren
ausbildung die griechischen steuerzahler
bezahlt haben arbeiten jetzt in
deutschland
die beratungen der beschluss organe der
ezb sind geheim der bloße versuch einer
einflussnahme auf die ezb etwa durch
demokratischen debatten und diskussionen
ist nach dem vertrag von maastricht
untersagt die ezb ist eine
internationale organisation die über den
gesetzen und zuständigkeiten der
einzelnen staaten steht ihre leitenden
mitarbeiter tragen diplomatenpässe und
die akten und dokumente innerhalb der
europäischen zentralbank können von
keiner polizeibehörde oder
staatsanwaltschaft durchsucht oder
beschlagnahmt werden
ws die ezb ist unter ökonomen als eine
der mächtigsten und in transparentesten
zentralbanken der welt bekannt doch ihr
ehemaliger präsident jean claude trichet
begegnete diesem problem mit der bloßen
behauptungen erst gebe kein problem
die ezb ist eine der transparentesten
zentralbanken der welt und hat dazu
beigetragen den stand der technik im
zentralbank wesen in diesem bereich zu
definieren behauptete er
weltwirtschaftsforum davos schweiz
mein name ist richard werner ich bin
wirtschaftswissenschaftler meine frage
richtet sich an herrn tre die frage ist
wo im vertrag von maastricht oder in den
ezb statuten steht das ist die aufgabe
die ezb ist strukturreformen oder eine
andere politische agenda zu unterstützen
ich habe sehr sehr deutlich gesagt und
wir haben immer wieder sehr sehr
deutlich gesagt dass wir in diesem
bereich keine verantwortung tragen wir
haben eine meinung und wir sagen was wir
denken und wenn wir dadurch dazu
beitragen können den menschen von
unserer seite aus zu erklären dass es
ihnen besser gehen könnte dann würde das
vielleicht europa dabei helfen mit der
umsetzung von strukturreformen zu
beginnen die so wichtig sind und darüber
gibt es einen konsens einen sehr sehr
großen konsens in diesem punkt
[Musik]
die europäische kommission eine nicht
gewählte interessensgruppe deren ziel es
ist vereinigte staaten von europa mit
allen merkmalen eines einheits staates
zu erschaffen hat ein interesse daran
die einzelnen regierungen und den
einfluss der demokratischen parlamente
europas zu schwächen
[Musik]
wie sich herausstellte stammten die
beweise für die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbanken auf die sich der vertrag
von maastricht stützte aus einer
einzigen studie die von niemand anderem
als der europäischen kommission selbst
den auftrag gegeben worden war
die 1992 unter dem titel ein markt eine
währung veröffentlichte studie
behauptete zu beweisen dass die
unabhängigkeit der zentralbanken zu
einer niedrigen inflation führt
james vor da ein wissenschaftler aus
oxford hat inzwischen nachgewiesen dass
diese studie manipuliert wurde um das
gewünschte ergebnis zu erreichen
die geschichte die uns von den
zentralbanken erzählt wird ist
widersprüchlich und es gibt beweise
dafür dass die zentralbanken anders
arbeiten als jetzt uns glauben machen
wollen
auf der ganzen welt haben die
zentralbanken bedeutende aber wenig
bekannte befugnisse oft unabhängig nicht
rechenschaftspflichtig und
undurchsichtig agieren zentralbanken im
verborgenen doch ihr handeln betrifft
uns alle
die zentralbanken in fast allen ländern
der welt und der iwf hat einiges dazu
beigetragen sind völlig unabhängig
geworden und praktisch keiner
demokratischen institutionen gegenüber
rechenschaftspflichtig
selbst die rechenschaftspflicht
gegenüber dem parlament ist in der regel
gering und in der praxis bedeutungslos
ob es sich um die japanische zentralbank
die federal reserve bank of england oder
die europäische zentralbank handelt
beispiele für den betrug der
zentralbanken gibt es viele in den
vereinigten staaten wurden die banken in
den 1920 er jahren ermutigt geld zu
schaffen und es an spekulanten zu geben
die daraus resultierende depression
überzeugte die freiheitsliebenden
amerikaner davon dass ein
dezentralisiertes föderales system ohne
starke nationale kontrollen nicht
funktionieren konnte
[Musik]
in den 1990 er jahren wurden die japaner
davon überzeugt dass ihr
wirtschaftssystem das beträchtlichen
wohlstand und gleichheit gebracht hatte
in ein so genanntes system der freien
marktwirtschaft umgewandelt werden müsse
transformation japans transformation war
noch nicht vollständig abgeschlossen da
schlugen die zentralbanker erneut zu und
zwar mit einem vom iwf angeführten
überfall auf die volkswirtschaften der
asiatischen tigerstaaten
die gegenwärtige europäische
schuldenkrise ist ein weiteres beispiel
für die täuschung der zentralbanken
einen öffentlichen konsens für die
notwendigkeit von strukturreformen zu
schaffen indem man absichtlich eine
rezession herbeiführt und sie dann
unnötig verlängert stellt einen
machtmissbrauch dar
die citizens relevant wollen die bürger
wirklich auf so kostspielige und
unehrlicher weise manipuliert werden
[Musik]
nach dem buch prinzen des yen von
professor richard werner
[Musik]